so welcome to the next video in the
equal repertoire series part 10 and this
sum and deals with one of the most
popular openings on a top grand master
level whoops which is some the green
felt
while green fade in German yeah it's a
very popular opening not only on the
grand master level and among world class
players but also on on the amateur level
and yeah quite understandably so because
it's a pretty active opening for black
often you get good on free development
with the only drawback of course that
white will build up a pretty big Center
often which you then try to fight with
your your pieces um of course it's it's
very popular on the world-class level
and this means there's no easy line to
learn to get a nice advantage
I recommend the line it's some topical
main line but I think it's one advantage
of this line is that if you face some
somewhat weaker players or players that
are not very well prepared they won't
have a really good answer I think
because somehow this some set up is not
so popular on lower lower rating levels
okay let's get right to it
that's an idea 3 Bishop g7 and Queen b3
the mattock Russian variation it's all
sometimes called um yeah white
immediately pressure rises thirty five
point and I think by far the best
option for black now is to just take on
c4 if black doesn't know the line
sometimes he plays c6 and this is rather
nice for whites who can just exchange
and develop which leads to a nice kind
of exchange Slav with the open sea file
but black has gone for the fianchetto
and this is not the best set up against
the exchange the Queen on b3 is also
putting some pressure on d5 and b7 let's
it's rather nice for white some black
players usually take on c4 and castle
now if for white grabbing the center and
now there's the really a huge parting of
the ways black has got yeah lots of
moves to choose from one important point
of the Queen position on c4 is then it
actually it's not so easy for black to
get in c5 which would be the normal kind
of way to attack the center because for
instance c5 the Queen is just able to
take or what you take with the pawn this
one is nicely protected so let's go a
bit through the lines here the oldest
line here Bishop g4 which was mostly was
mostly now it was was the most popular
line I think in the 50s and 60s when the
goon felt really became fashionable I
think it's a good idea to play in the
most aggressive way but should be three
not ft7 and then actually even long
castle on the same a possible line here
might be Knight b6 and now very
important on Queen c5 which really
prevents c5
as as directly as possible
Knight to d7 and Queen g5 which forces
black to to take on f3 d6 and h1 I just
stop here this is just an example line
of course because there are some other
possibilities for black um white as well
but it's just a line that I picked up
because it was played in a recent
Grandmaster game I think was Tomashevsky
where this Nippon Ichi - mm - tools
players with an ero rating above 2700
white one a nice game in general the
setup with the long castle it makes it
really hard for black to play c5 and I
think why this is a bit better here in
general the Bishop g4 also it's not not
the most popular move anymore um other
ideas Knight to a six this has been
played a lot by um then world champion
Kasparov and his matches against Anatoly
Karpov who played Queen b3 quite often
um he didn't have that great results
I think Kasparov in verse one or two
games and made a couple of drawers um
okay Amba should be to normal move c5 of
course this was the idea for 96 to
prepare this move then d5 d6 castles
each HC takes we should f5 rook e8 also
possible of course Bishop e3 rookie age
rook anyone this is maybe um yeah the
main line after 96 and certainly if you
intend to play this line it's a good
idea to to study some games
how the player must continued here in
general the main feature of the position
of course is white sir deep on which is
already a passed pawn and could be quite
dangerous
blacks counter play of course is some
mainly based on piece play naughty for
or night before at some point sometimes
there are also ideas of Queen b6 to be
for maybe so it's a good idea to study a
bit the games that have been played
results have been excellent for white
and I think it's due to this kind of
structure that night a6 has lost also a
little bit of popularity an interesting
line that is not played very often here
is Knight to c6
this actually was recommended in two
recent books and there have been quite a
lot of green for green red books and the
last couple of month even this was a
recommendation of both on
I think it's Grandmaster del chefs book
the safest green felt not sure if it's
really safe opening but it was nothing
to save his good friend and also
Grandmaster Boris a frog who published a
two-volume book you have two volumes of
more than thousand pages as a whole on
this opening also recommended 96 so it
has to be taken seriously of course
Bishop e2 should reform and then d5
would be my recommendation 95 I just
show the the main line this in general
this openness opening its M it's very
concrete very concrete variation so it
it's not possible I think to just in
West I don't know half an hour so and
then okay
you'll know what you're doing you will
need to invest a bit of time to to get
acquainted with the different setups and
move the orders that that black may
choose um I just showed show the
mainline castles which Queen b6 Queen a
497 and roof d1 I think this is the main
line and this is a point where it would
be useful to study some games that have
been played there has been a recent game
of Dutch number one initiative I think
was another young Grandmaster in the
Dutch championship where white really
got a great position out of the opening
this was with this exact moves so it's
interesting to to study this a bit
deeper um okay um what actually is the
main line on move seven here I think the
main line or the most most plate move
now nowadays is a six the Hungarian
variation I think this is called blacks
idea here is to play a quick B 5 and
then C 5 so for instance if white plays
Bishop e2 now which is which which is an
interesting alternative to the move I'm
I'm suggesting black will go for
immediate counter play which runs along
along this lines this is also
interesting if you invest some time here
I think it it also could be rewarding to
to look at this um this kind of line has
the advantage in a way compared to the
one I am suggesting that is rather safe
it can always if he wants to just
complete development like we should be
33 castles roopd one and we'll have a
safe position I think it's pretty sure
that there will be some trades on the
open C and D line so this could be a
safe alternative my my idea or not my
idea but the move I'm proposing here is
to play at the direct 'if I've which
leads to very sharp positions like that
in a place b5 sorry b5 Queen b3 and
retreats the night at this point they're
actually more than one interesting on
line
I suggest mainly H form here very direct
to go for h5 and open up the H file
other interesting moves here are 6 ft x
is six Bishop e3 - yeah well we can
weaken the structure in the center and
then switch attention even to the Queen
side with with a form this has been
played quite a lot it's quite funny
Black's main reply here is before Queen
before knight c6 I think it's really we
had weird position also interesting to
study another maybe interesting move
from here this Knight g5 which has been
played by what number one Magnus Carlsen
to win a nice game against a linear
Domingues from from Cuba I think about I
think beginning of this year I'm not I'm
not 100% sure
could also be interesting to to study
this moo-velous I think I'm not so well
known ok but the main suggestion would
be H form
then black goes for c5 e 6c form to get
the Queen out of this dangerous diagonal
Queen d1 back way to beat nitro b6 takes
on f7 route takes H 596 takes which
should be three I think I'll stop here
we're already on the move 16 but yeah
this is some of course a very very sharp
position white has succeeded in
weakening blacks King side he's only got
the unprotected g6 porn left so it it's
clear that this will be a very
unbalanced and sharp game in general the
Greenfeld is an opening which you I
think most of the time cannot approach
with some slow maneuvering kind of play
it's really the kind of opening where
you need to calculate exactly and and
precisely precisely is a better word and
and really fight black and sharp
positions so it's it's really a good
idea to to pick a line like Queen b3 and
do some studying there I think what is
really a rewarding of about shooting
this line is that I think that weaker
players or players who don't have such
an extensive theoretical knowledge will
get huge problems and if you've got a
really strong opponent you better have
done some work at home before thanks for
watching